peter thiel the famed billionaire
investor is stepping down from
facebook's board facebook recently
rebranded himself as meta and now peter
thiel the longest standing director on
their board of directors is stepping
down remember peter thiel made a 500 000
investment in the business he's been on
the board of directors since 2005. he's
one of the top venture capital investors
across silicon valley in the technology
industry peter will remain a director
until 2022's annual shareholder meeting
and he also has a lot of experience in
the technology industry he's the founder
of paypal and palantir technologies
peter knows a thing or two about
building out technology companies he
served as a right-hand man as a sounding
board for mark zuckerberg and other
executives at facebook but now he's
going ahead and stepping down so why
exactly is peter stepping down from
facebook's board a lot of people are
speculating it's because of his recent
move into the political arena peter has
been supporting many many different
candidates of course in 2016 he became
famous for being one of the first people
in silicon valley to support donald
trump's presidential campaign and of
course that ended up being a pretty good
bet as donald trump went on to win the
presidential election now peter has been
funding other candidates in this
upcoming election people like blake
masters or jd vance that he's close with
or that those people who work with him
and he's funding a number of other
candidates as well now whether that's a
conflict of interest or not i'll leave
other people to judge but of course it's
pretty hard for him to be funding a lot
of these political candidates while also
being a sounding board for facebook
because if those candidates start to
attack facebook now all of a sudden
peter's in a weird position ultimately i
think that he served a great run on the
board of directors of facebook he's done
a fantastic job helping shepherd that
company if we look at the last month of
their stock price they're down a lot
they're not about 33 and people are
worried but over the last five years
what we found is that facebook actually
has done really well they're up almost
65
over the last five years and so
ultimately regardless of what you think
of peter thiel regardless of what you
think about facebook and meta what we
know is that this has become one of the
most important largest technology
companies in the world they connect
billions of people every single day with
each other that communication is a net
positive for the world and now that
peter's going to step down one of the
big questions is what will the state of
free speech be on facebook and what is
the net impact of peter's decision not
to serve on the board of directors
anymore this is a story that will
continue to unfold and it's one to watch
but peter thiel stepping down just means
he's gonna spend more time focused on
other endeavors